it's so stressful but I don't know it's
like it's like the craziest thing in the
world yeah Billy Eilish isn't having it
with all the youtubers impersonating her
in public
after a bunch of videos were posted of
people rocking Billy's signature look
you know neon green hair roots and
oversized hoodies and shirts the bad
guys singer took to her Instagram to ask
people to knock it off Jesus Billy
shared this screenshot of one of the
videos where the impersonator is dressed
like her out in public surrounded by
security guards writing please stop
doing this it is not safe for you and it
is mean to people who don't know any
better this is real life but she didn't
stop there she shared multiple
screenshots of all the different videos
on YouTube featuring similar stunts
writing simply please stop so yeah Billy
isn't feeling all these impersonators
going out in public pretending to be her
but it's their wardrobe choices in the
videos that really grinds her gears snow
has always been something I care about
Billy shared this close-up of one
impersonators great chin high socks
writing also so disrespectful that you'd
go out pretending to be be wearing this
while the youtuber who is responsible
for the video Billy specifically called
out is named Jordan mater he shared this
post amidst all the backlash a pic of
the Billy impersonator who just so
happens to also be in Acrobat you can't
make this stuff up people in the caption
Jordan said he gathered a crowd around
and had an acrobat pretending to be
Billy do a huge cheer flip which reveals
it was not Billy
adding quote I had absolutely no
intention of disrespecting Billy I'm a
big fan like everyone else I thought it
was completely harmless since at no time
in the video are we pretending that she
is actually Billy
Jordan continued saying that he has
since reached out directly to Billy and
apologized
for sometime the ocean eyes singers post
comes just one day after she revealed
that she'll be performing at this year's
Oscar ceremony I'm just excited and just
a few days ago Billy became the youngest
artist and the first female artist to
ever sweep the top four categories at
the Grammys beyond your wildest dreams
oh my god how do you how do you take in
this moment oh you don't know a couple
years from now we'll be like remember
that one time I'm speechless speechless
so maybe Billy should just walk around
holding her Grammys then there'll be no
mistaking that she's the real deal and
the others are just fakes
just a thought of course you can count
on me to bring you all the latest on
Billy so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens see you soon
[Music]